welcome back to the program Chris Mannix
of Yahoo Sports NBA senior reporter how
you doing Chris
what's happenin you tell me we're gonna
have tonight we're gonna have the coach
of the year
accepting the trophy for his former team
right is that what we're gonna see
tonight you think yeah I think the way
in case he is is a pretty strong lock
just like I think James Harden for MVP
is a pretty strong lock if you could
choose to give up the award based on
April and May and June play who would be
the MVP choice for you Chris oh I think
it has to be LeBron you know that that
postseason was one of his best you know
and and look I voted for Harden and I
was comfortable with it it was just
LeBron during the regular season was
just too indifferent defensively a lot
but the way he strapped that team on his
back for you know a tough the toughest
Eastern Conference playoffs he's had in
a long time I would give it to him if we
factor that in where does his free
agency stance stand right now Chris it's
hard to get any kind of read on it and
it's hard to even guess I mean you're
just kind of reading tea leaves sort of
at this point and you know what you can
do is look at everybody else
that's kind of the best way to look at
LeBrons free agency because he always
goes to a place that has as good or
better expense to win a championship as
the place is leaving you know that's
been the history of LeBron James and you
know Kawhi
I don't think Kawhi gets dealt anywhere
whether it's the Eastern Conference the
Lakers I mean there's a lot there's a
lot of smoke screens out there right now
I mean now the latest is kind of Kauai
is not going to be traded out west you
know people that have dealt with the
Spurs have often told me that they're
they're not really all that concerned
with where Kauai go they're concerned
with the best return that they can get
back so I'm a little skeptical of the
idea that the Spurs are just ruling out
half the league in the talks about Kawhi
Leonard but wherever they decide to to
move him to ultimately it's not going to
be an accelerated process I mean we saw
Kyrie Irving dealt in late August last
year it wouldn't surprise me at all if
it played out that way with Kawhi
Leonard
nopal georgia me he'll happen his
decision will happen a lot faster but
you know I've been saying for weeks if
not months it's really since the
Oklahoma Seas season ended you know they
they have a quiet confidence in Oklahoma
City Paul George thoroughly enjoyed his
season there and you know if you talk to
people around him you talk to people in
on Russell Westbrook the relationship
between rust and Paul George really
strong you know they've spent time in
the LA area working out together this
summer
I don't discount the the strong
possibility that Paul George on some
kind of deal maybe it's on a full
five-year max but on some kind of deal
goes back to Oklahoma City for another
season
so look then let's let's hit the LeBron
part first of what you just said Chris
Mannix of Yahoo Sports joining us here
is there even a Dumb and Dumber chance
of LeBron tone the Cavs pick up my
option I'm staying put one year I only
think they tell him that or he tells
them that if he has something in place
where he'd be traded there I don't think
he's you know looking get the same
amount of money if not more I'm not you
know all that versed in the salary cap
gymnastics the teams are doing nowadays
to the clear cap space but he he'd get
as much money if not more just going
back to the caps the only reason talked
into his contract is because whether
it's Houston or somebody else he's
figured out a way to get to that place
without you know basically cutting that
team everything they have so that would
require him I mean is it tampering if
he's the one calling other teams Chris
now one thing one thing the NBA just
basically I mean they I don't know when
they decided this but it probably around
2008 when you know guys really started
paddling around these Olympic teams you
know they decide there's no such thing
as player tampering you know owners
can't talk you know they they get tough
on you know executives talking to agents
ahead of time you know they don't want
to hear about pre set up meetings or
magic talking to Kimmel you know
dropping a joke to Kimmel even like you
know that reported meeting with the
Lakers you know talking to their staff
look tampering for what I was told it
was like a meeting of the staff but
everybody was kind of talking to Magic
Johnson you know basically saying you
know don't you know go road all you
during this process because already got
burned once on this so you know that
kind of stuff that lit the NBA is as
tight as they can be on but players
doing stuff you know they they're just
not gonna police that so so LeBron is
the one who's calling daryl morey to
figure this out or he calls Chris Paul
to figure out like whether I don't think
LeBron is calling Darryl Morris I think
that it's player on player and you know
LeBron reaching out to Paul George
LeBron talking to Chris Paul these
conversations have to be happening you
know by now they happen all the time
amongst players maybe DeMarcus Cousins
is looped in on these you know tech
strains or whatever they are but there's
always a story behind how the kind of
sausage gets made out here and my part
of that story is always guys talking to
each other so you know maybe it's him
talking to Chris Paul to relays it's a
you know daryl morey I mean there's this
stuff that goes on behind the scenes
that that gets this kind of thing done
Chris Mannix of Yahoo joining me here
what are the what do you make of the
report that LeBron says don't PowerPoint
me bro like I don't need that when when
it's all up and running for the free
agency period Abbi the the being wooed
part of it is is really for first time
for agents and in first time for agents
on the level of LeBron James where we
saw you know Kevin Durant do it I mean
Kevin Durant was really a first time
free agent when he invited all those
people out to the Hamptons LeBron did it
his first time around when everybody
came out to sell him you know once you
go through that I mean even even Carmelo
spoke about this back to what was a 2011
or 12 when he signed that that deal he's
like I never want to go through that
again
it's an exhaustive process it's an
emotional process it's not fun I mean
guys want to do it because their end of
their contract they're 27 28 years old
they want teams out there drooling over
them but once they get through it they
don't want to do it again Ron
significantly scaled it back the last
time he was a free agent now it's gonna
be non-existent all right so how do you
see it what's your best guess in how it
plays out is it quick is it long does he
draw it out what do you think you got to
go off history rich and I think the
first time around it was like July 12th
the second time
Hawaii it was like an average like nine
nine 1/2 days of drawn-out stuff I would
imagine the same thing takes place I
mean he's got a unless he has that deal
which I'm skeptical of I think he signed
somewhere as a free agent unless he has
that deal in table I think we're looking
at the same time table you know 9th or
10th or 11th all right and Kauai doesn't
figure into this thing because I mean
based on what you heard draft night you
know
Buford basically coming out and saying
you know our our intention is to have
him here and be part of the family we
love them it has none of that affected
anything on this front why for what I've
been told they're trying to have it both
ways right now they're talking to Kauai
they're telling Kauai they want to be
there and when teams call it and I mean
literally every team in the league has
that's called either expressed interest
with an offer or just register their
interest you know they're telling teams
look we're not going to trade him but if
you want to make us an offer you know
we'll throw it on the pile here it will
we'll consider it they're not promising
to counter at this point they're just
saying make us a good offer and we'll do
it I had one GM that that described to
me the Spurs process for this is kind of
a blind auction and and that's why it's
going to be drawn-out I mean when they
ultimately do decide to make a deal on
this and you know I just don't think
it's salvageable you know with Kauai
saying I'll accept a long-term deal with
with San Antonio so when they decide
they could be a trade offer on this
they're gonna play one team against the
other I mean they I really believe that
a Kawhi Leonard trade whenever it
happens if it happens he's gonna be on
the same timetable at the Kyrie Irving
one so August not not trade deadline
like later on in the season oh yeah I'm
fully imagining rich like I had last
year with you know the one week of
vacation I take every year nice no being
drunk on a beach and getting a phone
call that a big player got ready yeah
but Kauai had I mean but Kyrie had two
years left on his deal and a lot of
people still think that he should be in
Cleveland still because of that the
amount of time left on the contract it's
not different because there's one year
left on Kauai steel well it it's no it's
a short answer is no it's not different
the Spurs the way they look at it
they're only deadlines the trade
deadline they still believe that Kauai
will have significant value leading up
that trade deadline now there's a
reasonable argument to be made that you
know Kauai value will diminish once the
season starts you obviously want to get
in your training camp working with your
team and equally it's important selling
him on the future of the organization
it's wait until February the number of
teams you can practically deal with goes
down pretty significantly so but the
Spurs they look at that February date as
being their real deadline so I don't
think they have any problem dragging
this thing out if the offers aren't
really appealing to them so I guess last
one for you there Chris you have lebron
popping right around them first if not
second week the after the first week of
July and Kawhi Leonard where that is the
Lakers how do you think they they look
by the end of July do they do they have
their max players do they have a
completely retooled team Chris you know
it it's a great question and I don't
know I mean this is this is as
unpredictable a free agency as I've ever
covered because even though the Miami
stuff back in 2010 it didn't really make
any sense once we realized that that
Bosh was in on it and and and all the
pieces that were in play it did make a
little sense Cleveland always made sense
because it was Northeast tile and you
know there were pieces because of all
those number-one draft picks that
they've had to to make a deal the Lakers
unless Paul George commits I mean that's
the big domino Paul George make the
decision is going to be the first guy to
fall maybe it simultaneously with LeBron
depict the Lakers but if Paul George
decides he wants to go back to Oklahoma
City I don't know where LeBron James
goes that he can look at and say that's
the team that I can win a championship
with ask the question of Chris as he
goes out the door here Chris yeah Chris
looking at the Rookie of the Year
nominees Ben Simmons Donovan Mitchell
Jason Tatum which of these guys would
you build your franchise around
ah I would probably pick Jason Tatum at
this point because I think Jason Tatum
it's only a handful of guys mislead that
have like average 30 points a game I
think Jason Tatum could average 30
points a game in this league he's that
good offensively Mitchell is like Dwayne
Wade type but maybe not there Simmons
has got to show me I mean we're talking
about Simmons guys that maybe he should
switch shooting hands next year like
you've got to get past that before I you
know take Simmons over Tatum long-term
Chris enjoy the NBA Awards tonight are
you going to be live-tweeting it
no I've got so many better things to do
I don't want to do that I don't care I
vote it I'm done written all right
you're done Chris thanks for the time
appreciate it you got it
you gonna add Chris Mannix why ass for
Yahoo Sports the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience